[Music]
we rarely see him
and he hasn't gone to any counseling and
my paralyzation comes from the fact that
i'm just so afraid i'm going to say the
wrong thing and cause him to feel like
he's a burden to us and then cause him
to take his own life you love that boy
huh
very much
[Music]
what's up this is john with dr john
delony's show so glad that you're with
us today
the
international
[Music]
best mental health show ever
from ocean to ocean i'm just it's not
hey i'm so glad that you're here you
talk about mental health relationships
all the stuff if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at 1-844-693-3291
it's
kelly you're 1-844-693-3291 at me with
your happy face am i missing something
no that was great you've done a great
job congratulations we've been on for 30
seconds
[Laughter]
the constant judgment and scrutiny that
i i endure it's just as a routine part
of my life
first i i i leave my home which is just
judgment scrutiny and i arrive here and
i stare directly into kelly's eyes
and it's judgment
oh
scrutiny
love it
and then there's america let's go to
carol in tucson what's up carol
hi john how are you i'm good how are you
um well i'm a little paralyzed with fear
to take action on something very very
important all right let me help you
yeah so our 33 year old son has been
hospitalized twice voluntary voluntarily
as being suicidal
one that the first one was in november
of 18 and the second december of 2019
and he's been living with us
and he pretty much just lives in his
bedroom
we rarely see him and he hasn't gone to
any counseling
other than at the very beginning of this
ordeal which we became aware of about
three and a half years ago
so my question for you is how do we
encourage him to go get counseling
um
and my paralyzation comes from the fact
that i'm just so afraid i'm going to say
the wrong thing the wrong thing
and cause him to feel like he's a burden
to us and then cause him to take his own
life hmm
i'm sorry this is happening
you love that boy huh
oh very much yeah
um has this
has he struggled his whole life
um he he at one time said to me he feels
like he's been depressed his whole life
but um you know he went on to do great
things he
um double majored in college went on to
the army
and became a captain and then when he
came out
went to seek a job that didn't come
easily as easily would have fought i
guess and
so my whole thought in this whole time
is that it was just the readjustment
coming out of the military that was very
challenging
so one of the
one of the challenges that parents
experience
when they have an adult child wrestling
with mental health issues
is a couple of things one
they try to roll back and see what they
could have done different to get to this
point and they carry a lot of blame and
a lot of shame a lot of shoulders or i
might haves or what ifs i had done this
is is that any any part of that your
story
um
well it's my story every day
now
not really retracing my steps but
i research the hell out of things um to
try to figure out what it is that he has
and what i should be doing
and what i should be saying and what i
shouldn't be saying
but he's treated by the va and he has
not allowed us to be privy to that
treatment okay
so
do you have two paths forward here
okay
one path
is to make peace
he's just going to use your house as a
hotel he's not going to be a member of
your family he's just going to
live in his bedroom
and extrapola i mean fast forward 10
years
he's going to be 44 and then go 10 years
after that he's me 54.
and um
just going to kind of be what he does
and he's going to be in his room on the
internet playing video games or whatever
and he's going to come out for dinner
that you're going to provide him he's
going to go back in there
and you're going to make peace with it
you're going to stop worrying about it
and
you're going to move on with your life
the other side of it is
you're going to say
this stops now
and here's what this stops means
if you're going to continue to live here
then
a part of you living here is giving us
access to your doctors so we can be a
part of your healing
because i'm just not going to i'm not
gonna sit ringside and watch my son die
and wither away to nothing
i'm not gonna watch my son
maybe not commit acute suicide pulling a
trigger or taking some pills or jumping
off something but i'm also not going to
watch him
commit what they call long tail suicide
just slowly fade away i'm not going to
sit down and watch that if that's want
to be the life that you want to choose
for yourself not that he's choosing
mental health and not issues and not
that he's choosing to hurt he's not
but if he doesn't want to choose to heal
then i'm not going to sit ringside and
watch that happen in my home
and honestly you as his mom and is dad
still in the picture
yes
you all two have to make that decision
on which path you want to take and
there's really only two paths the third
path you could take is to let them live
there and just fret and nag and
try new things and get a dog and then
get a
pool and do all these things and
mortgage your
you know take out a second mortgage on
your house and put you and your
husband's um
uh retirement in jeopardy oh you can you
could try a bunch of stuff but what
you're going to do is you're going to
you are going to drive yourself nuts
you're going to give yourself anxiety
and heart attacks and strokes and all
that prematurely right so
the the path forward is just making
peace
this is just going to be the way this is
or
we are going to draw some boundaries
aimed at healing with the understanding
that when we draw boundaries
other people can choose to draw their
own
and his boundary might be well then i'm
out of here
and you have to decide
is that better
than him being in his room slowly dying
is it better than him to go leave
somewhere
because right now he's not getting any
better
is that you hear what i'm saying
i do hear what you're saying so in in
that conversation as we take option two
or if we encourage option two or we draw
the boundary to go with option two
in that conversation is it that we're
making it more about
that we
like you said you don't want to see him
sit around and
die slow no see that's the thing i start
getting hung up on the words and that's
paralyzed yeah so let me let me show you
this you are not going to say a thing
and he's going to go no i haven't
thought of that now i'm going to go kill
myself
if you have a hard conversation with him
and he walks out of that room
and dies by suicide
that is not because you said the wrong
thing
okay okay that's because
he was struggling he wasn't well and he
made a decision
okay okay
the longer you don't have a conversation
the the messier this whole thing gets
and so when somebody
um
let me just let me put it this way i'm
not going to tell you what to do in your
world i'm going to tell you what would
happen if that was a friend of mine okay
if somebody calls and says um hey i
heard that so and so one of our buddies
is struggling
and this happened somewhat recently i
hung up the phone i picked them up and i
called and said hey
i heard you're not doing okay and they
explained some stuff and then i cut them
off and said hold on before you keep
talking are you going to kill yourself
and you want to talk about like
no man my kids and i was like no no
that's not what i'm asking i need you to
tell me yes or no are you going to hurt
yourself
no
now i didn't
put a thought into this person's head
that wasn't suddenly there
it was like no way i didn't think of
that yeah now that's not how that works
okay
um okay people do respond to boundaries
particularly if they have
deep mental illness
he could respond in an extreme way
okay there is that possibility
um
that would not prohibit me and my house
from taking taking having that
conversation
let me think of it this way okay
not um
let's say somebody uh has colon cancer
um and they're on some sort of
experimental um chemotherapy
and
they're not taking their chemotherapy
drugs and we've heard about stories
where we're out of nowhere somebody goes
to the doctor for their annual checkup
and it's just gone the tumor's gone it
just went away
and also they say hey
colon cancer is a bad one let's do lung
cancer and then um
or they just call me just keep smoking
at some point i'm gonna say
you cannot sit in my house and continue
to smoke
and they may say
um if you send me out of here i'm gonna
die
you are sending me to my death
nope i'm not
i'm offering you
life if you stay here we're going to
walk alongside you we're going to give
you a place to live we're going to give
you food we're going to give you water
we're going to give you shelter and
we're going to have a close connection
with your doctor
and that's your rent for being here
you can choose to keep smoking
i'm not going to watch you do it
i can't
[Music]
and i'm willing to offer you something
else does that make sense
yeah it makes a lot of sense
the challenge here is um
it might be something like this uh i if
i were you i'd also call the va
and i would let them know they can't
even acknowledge that he's a client
there um or wherever he gets is he
taking meds of any kind
yeah okay
you can look on the pharmacy i mean you
can look at the pharmacy whatever doctor
wrote that prescription you can see that
yes
i would send that doctor a note
of some sort or call
and say i know you can't confirm that my
son's even a client because he's 34.
we're about to have a hard boundaries
conversation in our home
and he has a history of suicidality
if this is a bad choice please let me
know
and put that burden on them
okay okay
but that's what i would do okay
and then there's a ethical obligation if
they know that there have a client in
harm's danger in harm's way
that this
you know maybe
your son told them if they ever do this
i am immediately going to do this in
this way at this time then they would
have an obligation to come out and say
something
okay
okay you are between a rock and a hard
place
there's no question about it
the question you have moving forward is
am i going to make peace with the way
things are
or am i going to draw a boundary and
tell my son i want to be a part of your
healing
and i'm not going to sit here and watch
you slowly fade away in my home
okay
as a follow-up to that he at the
beginning he had delusions and one of
his delusions was that his father was
not his father
so
i you know i don't know where he stands
on that right now the medication seems
to have taken care of the delusions but
for that reason should his father not be
part of this conversation
um i would ask him tell him we have to
have a hard conversation about our live
your living arrangements here
and would you like um i want dad to be a
part of this conversation but in the
past you have expressed that you didn't
know if dad was dead
um
are you okay with him being a part of
this conversation
okay and i just i would just have it
that way
um okay actually you know what i'll take
that back i absolutely take that back
yes i would have dad a part of the
conversation
i would okay here's why
um this is your house and this whole
conversation is a boundary where we're
reclaiming our home
and we're reclaiming our rightful place
as your parents
and as your parents we're going to tell
you her truths and we're going to love
you
and so this is your dad
and
if you've taken your medication and
you're part of a healing community
then you would know that or you would at
least understand and trust us
right or trust your anyway
um
is that making sense
sure so i would have that this is a
reclamation thing but i need you to hold
this really like what i'm about to tell
you right now i need you to hold this in
your hand
this can all go south
and the question you have to ask
yourself is
is it worth that conversation
and what i will tell you is for me yes
for me yes
for the students for those folks i've
walked alongside year after year yes
it might be that you ask somebody from
the va to join you in this conversation
at home
it might be that you have the va on
standby or some sort of other mental
health professional in the community on
standby
it may be that you've got
two or three people that you trust that
are friends of the family that maybe he
trusts or a couple of his friends or
maybe one or two friends from service
with him
you will know best the ecosystem with
which to have this conversation
and it might not be just one
conversation it might be multiple
but at some point we set a deadline and
say hey you're not getting better
you're struggling
if you're going to live here
you're going to be a part of this family
and here's what that looks like
and depending on where his mental ill
how severe his mental illness is he may
be
just i mean unable to function at 100
great
here's what based on what you can do
here's what we're asking of you
we've got to have signed releases with
your doctor so that we can be a part of
your healing journey gotta know what
meds you're taking and i get to check in
on you periodically to make sure you're
taking your meds
if you're struggling with delusions or
suicidal you're gonna let somebody know
that's an agreement that you make as i
promise you make to your mom and dad to
live in our home
some of those things right we're going
to be very clear on our boundaries
and you've got to have people to walk
alongside you as you rev these
conversations up because it's going to
be hard
and he may walk right out that door
okay i don't envy you in a
the slightest bit
i'm heartbroken for you but i also know
shying away from this is making the
whole house tense and the whole house
filled with smoke let's open the windows
up and let's have that conversation
get a professional walk alongside who
will walk alongside you in this okay
don't do this by yourself thank you so
much for the call we'll be right back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's go to mac in
loveland colorado what's up mac
hey how you doing good brother how are
you man
i'm all right all right so what's up
dude
um
i need help kind of
figuring out
uh if and then
maybe where i'm being too hard on
my wife and our relationship and
what makes you think you're being too
hard
um
[Music]
some of it is whenever we have
conversations specifically about
harder stuff
more serious things what's harder um
when it comes to what our family looks
like moving forward
in regards to
[Music]
kids where we want to live stuff like
that or even just
any hard topics that come up in the
world just naturally
i i like to talk about those things
and sometimes i feel like i might force
them onto her but she tends to
shut down
not talk about things and
push them away or at least that's how it
feels to me and i don't know if i'm
putting her in a position to do that
um
and on top of that our relationship just
kind of feels like it's been rocky since
we've been married okay
well i'll just start the call with
saying thank you for being brave man
that's a hard phone call to make have
you told anyone else that you're
struggling with this
uh yeah so my friends okay
what do they say
um
depending on the topic you know
it sometimes you know depending on the
friend turns into a
you know kind of comparing thing about
relationships and i try to stay away
from those and then some of them tell me
that you know things will work
themselves out and when things move
forward like you know with kids for
example that you know people just kind
of be able to step it up because they'll
have to and
but i kind of get a little bit of
everything and so that's why i don't
really know where to go yeah i
appreciate the trust man um so when your
wife shuts down
um
when she shuts down
and you ask her about it what does she
say
um
not a whole lot i mean that's kind of
part of the problem is he shuts down and
there are times where i know that i get
a little too frustrated for it and not
in like i'm yelling kind of way it's
just i'm clearly frustrated and i'm
i've been trying really hard to
recognize when it's happening and take a
step back and maybe come back to it
later but even when i don't do that it
still just feels like it goes nowhere
words don't come out
and it just becomes like this like
circular conversation
what's what's what's your goal for the
conversation are you really trying to
get to hey let's go ahead and nail down
how many kids we want to have or where
do we want to live or is is this your
way
of
trying to be intimate trying to connect
um
i would say
both but probably more towards the like
actually trying to figure things out
okay y'all been married two years how
old are you
i'm 27. okay
uh when i was 27 we were gonna have four
kids and i was cool at stopping with
three
and we were gonna live probably in
houston texas was my guess
and now i've got two kids
we're done and i live in nashville
never not even on the radar
and so what is your
what is your impulse to try to nail this
down why do you need this nailed down
right now at 27.
i don't even necessarily want to say
nailing it down it's
i just want to be able to talk about
some of these things and it seems like
we can't like like it kind of started at
first as she's getting ready to turn 30
and so it's you know doing the whole
like i'm 30 30 and getting old kind of
thing and i've got seven great hairs
that kind of thing has been going on and
then it's turned into i'm you know on
like she's brought up you know i'm on a
timer now with the whole baby thing and
we gotta think about this and for me i
i more want to make sure that our
relationship is strong enough to where
when we bring a child into the world
that it's in a good place that's the
best place that i can make it
what is that what does that look like
um
you know a strong a strong family
between her and i i know
but be very specific what's a strong
family between her and i because here's
what i here's what i hear just in your
language
is very amorphous
and some of that may be because you're
nervous on the radio but but it it's
very
the way you communicate even with me is
is somewhat circular and somewhat
amorphous
okay
just even the way like um tell me what
hard things you know it's just things
that we're talking about what our
families might family might look like
down the road when
instead of saying how many kids are we
gonna have and where we're gonna live
and what she wants to do as a career you
see what i'm saying like one of those
very direct here's what i'm trying to
get answers to
and i can imagine if somebody's hinting
around hey i'm 30
and i'd love to have a family with you
and we've been married for two years and
you're like well
i kind of have this
thing about what the
it's going to look like and i want to
make sure we're strong
that's telling her
i'm still trying you out
and i don't have any clear criteria for
you
my guess is she has learned to shut down
she that's usually a behavior people
pick up in their childhood
but it is a feudal
like this conversation will go nowhere
and will have no bearing
on there's nothing i can say in this
conversation that's going to have any
impact on my life whatsoever except
possibly negatively so i'm out
okay
and
i don't know what you're waiting for or
what kind of metric i've got friends in
my life that's like i wanted to have x
number of dollars in the bank before i
had a kid that was a security blanket
for me i wanted to to have this level of
position at a job until i realized every
job is fungible and the higher up the
latter you go the more likely you are to
get fired i didn't know anything like so
i i had all these imaginary things
but it was pretty clear here's where
we're gonna start having a kid my wife
and i weren't trying out right we wanted
to both be done with grad school we both
wanted so we had some very clear metrics
it doesn't sound like you have those
you just have this idea that i kind of
wanna
am i wrong
um
kind of just maybe just a little bit
nervous because okay i'm calling in
that's cool and that's totally fine
totally fine
some of it specifically is
you know her and i
were maybe intimate
once every two or three months and we're
only two years in and it's been that way
practically since we got married okay
and
i try to talk with her and figure out
what's going on with that
there's a thing that always
not always uh it comes up frequently
okay where she
kind of gets in her own mind and she's
told me this so this isn't like me
saying it
where she gets in her own mind she
essentially like catastrophizes a lot of
things specifically like death and
freaks out and goes into a spiral she's
woken me up in the middle of the night
like crying and bawling and i'm like i
don't know what thank you i wasn't
trained for this um
so like there's things like that and i
think a really big thing that
i may be conflating the two things but
it's also trying to figure out
i she went through a lot when she was
younger with her family
and
i
am worried that it's kind of affecting
things now and that it could affect
our family going forward so let me tell
you both of you
both of you went through things as a
child that is affecting your
relationship right now
100 chance yes
the only question you have moving
forward is
are we two gonna work together
to heal from what was and create
something awesome moving forward create
something new create something strong
create something beautiful create
something of our own devising moving
forward that's the only question you
have
and the answer to some folks is no
i'm going to live in the past i'm going
to always be this person who is abused
traumatized neglected left whatever the
word is
that is going to be who i am
and then unfortunately you as somebody
married to that person have to decide
is this the life i'm signing up for
am i gonna just ride this one out
or am i out of here
or
the other side is we're gonna we're
gonna change everything
have you said hey i wanna go see a
counselor together
yes okay and she said no
um she just said yes
the problem our biggest problem is
scheduling but that's just an excuse um
100 actually do it 100 excuse me
and so what you can do is take the lead
because this sound like
the shutting down thing and the being
hard thing that what it sounds like is a
house filling up with pressure of
frustration
she's frustrated at how she responds and
how she feels because she wants to feel
different as your husband
i mean as your wife and she wants to
feel different as x and wants to feel
different it's why
and you want to experience this you want
to experience that and
none of that is happening
and you're walking and talking past each
other and you're living past each other
you're only having sex two or three
times i mean two once every two or three
months
um
and you're frustrated by that she's
frustrated by that and then all of a
sudden
it's because baby becomes the issue or
where we're gonna live becomes the that
becomes the volcano but man it's been
churning underneath
here's the frustrating part all you can
fix on planet earth is you
that's it yes
and so if i'm you
i'm gonna go sign up for my own
therapist asap
okay
i'm gonna go say i'm gonna start dealing
with me
i'm gonna start going to the gym
i'm gonna start doing these things to
for me to be healthy and me to be well
on me to be whole
i'm gonna get a job that i actually feel
like i'm right i'm gonna start doing
these things and every time i'm gonna
invite my wife along
i'd love for you to join me i'd love you
to come be a part of this
right is that fair yes no that's fair i
guess
how and i know i can't obviously force
her into doing anything but how can i
maybe ask her
to
get help with me or you know alongside
me or something like that with
stuff that she's been through because
that's kind of
it all kind of seems to go back to
something she went through when she was
younger and still connected to
specifically
to keep it as friendly family family
friendly as possible hey we're way past
that on this show dude we're way past
that
fair enough um her dad isn't her
biological dad when she was eighth or
ninth grade went to prison for the rest
of his life for recording himself with
children his niece okay and
so her dad her dad was a pedophile
yes and mentioned her in a recording and
she
says nothing ever happened with her
but that's kind of was her starting
point and she still talks to him on the
phone he is still
abusive to her like every time she gets
off the phone with him
i just hear it in her voice and i try
talking to her about it and then it
turns into well i thought you weren't
gonna get like i thought you weren't
gonna make it no you were my dad and
it's like
right so here's the way forward there
if you have a conversation in that right
at the end of that phone call you're
talking to somebody who's in such
escalated fight or flight there is no
conversation happening there there's
survival only
there's a conversation to be had that
says hey i'm gonna make breakfast on
saturday we're gonna do this one at home
and
um
i want to tell you some things
i'm not going to ask you for your
response in any of these things but i've
got some things that have been on my
heart and in my chest and i want to tell
you
how many times would i try that because
i've
tried that a few times i think one time
i'd write a letter
okay and i would read the letter and i
would leave it with her
and when you start to have this
conversation she may shut completely
down not hear a word you're saying just
try to survive
she's had to survive her whole life
in that letter if she'll go back to it
and go back to it and go back to it
she'll see this man's different and this
man loves me
this man sees me and this man wants me
to be whole
and you get to she'll get to choose
moving forward
ultimately she's going to have to decide
i want to get well and a wellness
journey for her is gonna be hard and you
have to
convince her that i'm gonna be right
here with you
but yeah i can do that i can imagine
she's got
sex and intimacy for her is
war it's terror
right it's hard
probably yeah
and she might not even know that
or it's disgusting because it was used
as a way to hurt children you know
there's a million different ways her
body can take that all that to say is
this is going to be the definitive
conversation i need you to get well
i can't hear that man's voice in my home
i don't want him calling our house
and if you need to talk to him
more than me then i'm gonna have some
hard conversation i'm gonna have some
hard decisions to make because every
time this man calls and talks to my wife
she gets hurt all over again
and i love you too much to
does that make sense i love you too much
to let you continue to talk so
negatively about yourself here
i guess i'm worried that that's going to
be an ultimatum and i
what's your alternative man
just keep floating along like you are
look up and it be five years from now
and she's more withdrawn and y'all had
sex four times in five years i mean
what's the what's the alternative
i mean that and that's i guess what i'm
scared of and why i really want to
where this usually ends
is in ash in resentment
somebody ends up running into a
co-worker that makes their heart beat a
little bit faster
or they find some websites that make
their heart fee beat a little bit faster
or they start working 130 hours a week
and make themselves busy
or they have one more drink and one more
drink
because when our relationships aren't
whole there's an entire ecosystem that
will take that pain from us and just
distract us distract us distract us
distract us
i'm not telling you to make an ultimatum
but you're gonna get there at some point
i will not accept x and i will accept y
the the
the faster you can get there the more
peace you're going to have because right
now it's just this ambiguous yeah i
don't know
i don't you know what i mean i don't
know it's kind of
the more you live there the more your
body is trying to solve it solve it
solve it solve it solve it solve it
i guess i'm just scared to be specific
because of where it could lead and
scares the crap out of me i get totally
get that
but just know this the ambiguity's
killing you
and the ambiguity is killing her too
because she doesn't want your
relationship to be where it is either
so some specificity
it's like when people are getting out of
debt
and they know they owe a bunch
it's like dude you got to write down how
much you owe somebody
or when people's eating is out of
control like mine has been the last
couple of months
i
my dr norton my buddy lane gave i mean
he said dude i've got the best
product on the market and just start
measuring what you eat dude i had that i
had that app
for a while before i had the courage to
start going like all right i gotta just
start and dude i didn't like it i
haven't i i've loved the app i've not
liked the
reality of my eating habits
when my wife sits down we have budget
conversations i don't like the reality
of my spending habits but their reality
right and so that specificity helps us
have a starting point and right now you
guys are just living this amorphous
tension and when you live in the
amorphous you both default to
the things that your body knows
hers knows to withdraw yours knows to
try a little bit harder and have a
different conversation
and those aren't working
and so at some point we have to say
here's the status of our relationship
we've slept together three or four times
the last year every time the pedophile
calls our home and i know he's your dad
you feel like this every time i want to
talk to you about the future this
happens
[Music]
and i need something different
i need you
and i'll be a part of your healing
journey this can be hard but yeah i
think specificity is really important at
this in this season
what do you need and what does she need
and how can you help each other get
there
we'll be right back
hey john deloney here and people i'm
getting fired up it's finally warmer
outside and it's starting to stay light
longer and you should be spending more
time outside going for a run playing
with your kids at the park or just doing
a bunch of yard work i know that i'm
doing all those things but when you're
running hard you must remember to
recharge your body with a good night's
sleep and that starts with a quality
mattress like a dream cloud
dream cloud's combination of gel memory
foam and coil technology keeps you
comfortable all night long and that
means you can go all out all day because
you're actually getting solid restful
sleep at time right now dream cloud is
offering their biggest deal ever
exclusively for our listeners when you
buy a dream cloud mattress you get 499
in sleep accessories plus an additional
250 discount that's 749 dollars in
accessories and savings start getting
the rest your body needs visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress and 749
in savings today
all right we are back this has been a
heavy show so uh we're calling an
audible here we're gonna take a left
turn
um first but before we make that turn
we're just in the turning lane
is that the uh that was annoying i'm
sorry that was the turn signal i was
trying to make a turn signal because i'm
gonna be a conscious driver hey this
book essentialism by greg mccowan go buy
it
it's been out a while i'm way late to
the game here this book is
extraordinary and i don't want to give
it away other than
this is the single best book i've ever
read on
how to make the most important things in
your life the most important thing and
actually go get them done
an absolute masterpiece essentialism by
greg mccowan all right so
now we're turning
and here's a new segment called delony
was wrong
i just made that segment up
kelly's like ooh
i like this segment i'm in for this yes
um so
i i'm always giving advice and running
my mouth and blah blah on the show i
don't think yeah i guess i do give
advice or i give my opinion on things or
what i would do in my situation um
but sometimes i'm wrong and i think it's
important as
scientists i think it's important as
people who are um
espousing their views on things to say
yeah i miss this one and here's one
where i missed it
and i brought some friends in to help
so i have for years talked about the
importance of loneliness and i mean the
import not the importance of loneliness
the importance of having friends having
community
and how awful loneliness is and how it
kills us both physiologically and
emotionally psychologically spiritually
we just die younger right we're not
designed to live alone
and
i also think it's i thought it's really
not a good idea to become best buddies
to have your intimate go-to folks be
people that you work with
because there comes a moment when i may
have to fire you
or i may have to tell you that i blew
something up in my marriage or that i
took money that wasn't mine i did
something that's gonna force you to
think of the business
that we both share
or the workplace that we both share and
you're gonna have to consider my actions
there too
which is gonna make me be less
open
less vulnerable less honest and that's
not friendship damn we have secrets we
have things that i don't tell here and i
don't tell there so i've always been a
big fan of gotta have
good working relationships no question
about it you got people that you trust
no question about it
but your 2 a.m friends don't need to be
at work with you they need to be out
elsewhere
you don't need to be sitting around
talking about work all day long all that
stuff
and then my buddies ryan and josh of the
minimalist
swung swing by
and part of our conversation when
they're here i asked him hey
y'all are best of best friends
and y'all run this company together the
minimalist
and in this company you are always
giving each other opinions and advice
and you all differ on a lot of stuff
how do y'all remain friends and run this
business and
we talked about loneliness talk about
friendship
but i gotta say i was wrong
and i've they this conversation actually
changed my opinion
on
forcing me to rethink this idea of
um
not being friends close friends of
people you work with so
check out this conversation i have with
my good friends josh and ryan of the
minimalist on loneliness
friendship and working with friends
right here
i want to talk about
um loneliness and friendship um okay um
so here's the here's the the some of
this is spurred on by your book love
people use things because the opposite
never works which i think is the
greatest title in the last three or four
years of a book thanks thank you so um
we did a survey here a national survey
this is a research um back survey here's
some of the data points we came out came
back with 82 percent of people say
they're friends and people they spend
most of the time their most of their
time with don't know them deeply
so eight out of ten okay
um believe that folks don't know they're
struggling with their weight or their
faith or they're not attracted to their
spouse anymore that they like bieber's
music like they really like it but their
friends don't know that who doesn't
exactly
68
say they have three or fewer close
friends right so seven out of ten
more than half do not have a
friend they feel comfortable calling in
the middle of the night
and half about fifty percent of married
couples admit to struggling with sexual
intimacy um and emotional intimacy they
can't tell the one person that they
committed
like you're my right or die i can't tell
even that person
so going back to the title of your most
recent book is love people use things
because absent never works i've been
speaking about loneliness for years but
after spending time with you guys i've
got a new perspective and it's this i i
wonder if it's rooted in a consumer
culture
it tells us i can get all the stuff that
i need so that i can be okay and i can
do life by myself so here's my broad
questions and we can run this wherever
we want to
what's your thoughts on a life will
lived because that to me is the end and
if we reverse engineer that to what does
it look like in the in the hour by hour
and minute by minute we can get to some
of these answers um and what's the
importance of community and friends um
let's start by talking about the
commodification of love okay because
that's really what we've done you sort
of alluded to it there we we treat
relationships transactionally so the
title of the book was love people use
things because the opposite never works
ryan and i tried the opposite for a very
long time loving things oh and we hear
it all the time i love my truck i love
my house yeah and but i also love my
wife right same word yes we don't have
different words to describe what we're
really trying to say here is i enjoy
this truck right but also what we're
saying is this truck says something
about me this couch says something about
me nothing wrong with owning a truck i
own one nothing wrong with owning a
couch i own one right but as soon as it
becomes part of my identity a lot of
people are struggling with identity
right now and the way that we think we
have a shortcut to identity is what by
heaping
new masses of things the average
american household has 300 000 items in
it and that'd be great if it was
bringing us more joy more connection
more community however i will say this i
want to be careful not to prescribe
something because having more friends
isn't better that's relationship
consumerism it's it's and it's been
amplified with social media right i've
got 3 000 friends on the internet i just
got nobody to come help me fix my air
conditioner right right i've got all
this but i have nothing i have friends
in quotes but i don't have the people
who i have that intimate relationship
with i will say this i have two really
deep friendships in my life one is ryan
one is my wife it doesn't mean that i
don't have other friends i can turn to
and i'm grateful for those friends but
the relationships that i that i have
i've cultivated in a way where i don't
need a thousand relationships
because with same thing with material
possessions i own some things and i get
immense value from those things but
relationships are different it's not
just about getting value from the people
in my life that's a parasitic
relationship it's also about
contributing to the people around me in
the book we wrote about the three
different types of relationships sort of
the primary relationships in our life
usually you can count those on one hand
if you're mormon or catholic it's two
hands
so your your closest friends your family
your kids maybe your parents to a
certain age but beyond that you have the
sort of secondary relationships those
are the people who are the
other cast members in your film so to
speak the people that you love that you
care for that you appreciate
and
those people
we often spend
a decent amount of time but we
unfortunately forsake the people closest
to us spend time with those people or
the third layer of people the sort of
tertiary relationships the people on the
periphery we spend a lot of time with
people who are co-workers and networking
buddies and acquaintances nothing wrong
with those people but if i'm spending 95
percent of my time
away from the people that i love that i
care about i'm not making time for them
but i'm also not making time for my most
important relationship was my my
relationship with me yeah
yeah
yeah i think like there's this um in
incompleteness that maybe everyone kind
of feels a little bit and we're always
finding trying to find a way to be
completed and the things is a shortcut
to that and we get told by 5000
advertisement today that here's what's
going to complete you
and i would even posit that it's not
that people complete us either
i think
we can have meaningful relationships
once we kind of realize that we are
complete by ourselves
and uh
yeah i mean you know josh and i luckily
we knew each other in grade school so by
proximity we became friends
but often like people are stuck with
proximity with friends and they kind of
you know
start to friend people who um they see
every single day and these relationships
aren't always the best relationships
right right they're convenient right
yeah right so i um and we've talked
about this in other places but
that when our brain recognizes that
we're alone
it can be
proximal or it can be emotional right
and we've all probably had experiences
when i'm surrounded by people that quote
unquote love me and that i love but i
feel totally alone right yeah and vice
versa you can be with that one i was
with two
knuckleheaded dudes this weekend in
texas that i've known for
and i was completely
and i think it's i love that other
people don't complete you
for me or i think for our neurologically
other people allow our brains to go
and then we can i can look in the mirror
and see the truth right then i'm not
trying to fight and look for the right
label that completes me i love that yeah
so uh what's you mentioned you got two
really important ride or dies in your
life what about you man yeah uh you know
i'm a pretty big extrovert okay so i
make friends really really easy and i
live in los angeles which
has some amazing people like there's so
many i can't even um hang out with them
all it's like i find myself like you
know struggling to hang out with this
person i hang out with that person but i
mean as far as like close tight-knit
relationships uh my wife josh
um and then there's a couple other uh
they're probably more secondary okay um
but yeah i i do
enjoy hanging out with people and i you
know i think a lot of people would
probably call me their friend
um and vice versa uh but yeah man as an
extrovert i yeah i try to seek out as
many people as possible i love it you
know you brought up um a life well-lived
yeah and it's interesting because um
if we're not clear on what we want out
of life
uh we can find ourselves
you know forging these bonds that really
aren't that strong of bonds so how do
you figure out what you want well uh
josh and i i mean we talk a lot about
how it starts with your values like you
got to get clear on what it is you value
and you can go to the minimalists.com
forward slash v as in values and there's
actually a worksheet there
that um help you unpack the different
things that that you
that you want to get out of life and
that's really the meaningful life it's
our short terms our short-term actions
aligning with these long-term values
yeah and sometimes we choose friends and
we don't really line those two up right
and uh you want to unpack the like i
want i want to be successful
and i surround myself every day with
folks who just want to get high right
yeah exactly so i'm trying i've tethered
myself here and i'm running yeah yeah
yeah um do you want to unpack the the
different layers of values yeah sure i
mean our values aren't what we yeah
quite often not what this we say they
are i can say my health is a value my
relationships are a value of mine but if
all i'm doing is out you know getting
drunk and and uh you know whatever it is
like it
though however you spend your time those
are your actual values yeah so what we
talk about with that worksheet um
you have four different types of values
and so you sort of it's like building a
house every house has a foundation
every foundation is pretty much the same
well hey what do you want your
foundation to look like john no one asks
you that because a foundation dirty yeah
right and so everyone has similar
foundational values relationships health
contribution creativity passion etc
there are these different foundational
values fairly similar beyond that though
what makes your house look different
makes you different individual are the
structural values the structure of your
house can be a little bit different your
walls are going to be in different
places some people want a giant open
floor plan other people want six
bedrooms and
nothing is right or wrong there it's
what's appropriate for you right yeah
beyond that you have surface values
that's what makes your house look
interesting or beautiful right so like
what or what are you going to paint the
house what kind of facade are you going
to have right now we misprioritize these
things we were talking to dave ramsey
yesterday i was at the airport um a
couple weeks ago
and there was this terrible shooting
that happened
and they it was on the news at the
airport and they broke in breaking news
verdict on the johnny depp amber heard
tribe
and that's what we're doing with our
personal lives right now is is we're
breaking news with banalities and sort
of
the vapid you know cultural references
that make us feel some sort of dopamine
hit in the moment right
but it doesn't complete us right now i
will say a thing about the complete
thing quite often that we experience a
void and emptiness right
and we try to fill that void with stuff
with relationships with chemicals or
substances whatever it is as opposed to
realizing like hey i'm already complete
and the void isn't a bad thing
necessarily emptiness isn't a bad thing
yeah we lived in montana for five years
no one goes to
the mountains they're like that is so
freaking empty here
we're gonna fill this the sky is too
empty yeah you know what we need
consumer purchases that would be great
put some bounce houses out here on the
field
yeah and so i think also recognizing
that empty feeling that we experience as
that pascal quote about all of
humanity's problems stem from man's
inability to sit alone in a worm quietly
yeah and that is that's us yeah we
we can't sit here and be comfortable
with the emptiness so we try to fill it
not recognizing we're not filling it
we're just cluttering the space
so i
i have struggled with this personally in
my professional career
and
any tips you all have
we you mentioned earlier we spent so
much time with the people that we work
with
and early on in my career
i was working with some of my best
friends in the world yeah and we
ended up in the same
worship places we ended up in the same
grocery stores in the same movie
theaters and the same we watch the
fights together whatever
and then it comes the day when one
person screws up or there's a there's a
moral violation or character violation
or they lose their job and
and suddenly you can't go to the grocery
store you can't go to the movie theater
because your circle's untethered and so
i wrongly hit the pendulum too far and
said
all of my close relationships are going
to be the people that i don't do work
with every day and i've come to believe
that i screwed that up i hit i went too
far
um
with without like
this can get kind of irony kind of fast
um so we don't have to do that but
how have you two managed to stay close
friends and also do business together
because there's an inherent tension
there you know yeah no that's a great
question you know i think
josh and i well first off i see him as a
mentor and i think he probably looks at
me as a little bit of a mentor so we
have this like very
uh
very symbiotic relationship that um we
both hold very dear yeah and i think
with a business partnership a friendship
a romantic partnership
i mean the whole goal is we have a
romantic partner no i'm talking about
[Laughter]
regardless of the kind of relationships
that we have in our life what do we want
out of those relationships regardless of
whether it's romantic or not we want to
be understood we want to be respected we
want to be seen
and and that is really what i go out of
my way to do with all of my
relationships i go out of my way to um
you know not just do that but also add
value to that relationship there's like
a
um
an us box right like how how much are
you how much am i giving to this us box
is something i will ask of myself a lot
and if i'm not giving anything to it and
the relationship is tumultuous then i've
got to look in the mirror and be like
okay what have i not done that i really
should probably do to get this
relationship back on track and i think
you know the the thing that really kind
of screws up relationships a lot are
expectations you know we've got all
these expectations especially the ones
where you know uh you you expect uh you
know someone to do something and they
don't they don't do it and then you get
mad yeah because they didn't do it but
they didn't even know about that
particular expectation exactly right so
i mean i think that's another piece of
it too is like i don't expect anything
of josh i don't expect anything of my
wife um i uh the only thing i expect is
for myself to hold a high level of
standards and i think that's um what
really helps me
do great with relationships low
expectations high standards
yeah
john i got to tell you that that one of
the biggest things that has helped
ryan's in my relationship is a lack of
self-righteousness
because he and i have different
political beliefs we voted for two
different people in the last election
can you believe it oh my god um and you
know we have different religious beliefs
spiritual beliefs and we have different
personalities as well
and it'd be easy for me to to stand on a
pedestal and say well you know i'm right
i'm going to drag ryan up to this
pedestal with me and until he gets up
here i'm going to look down on him and
it'll be easy for him to do the same
thing to me i'm going to look down at
you because you're not on my level we
have different opinions about something
right but opinions often block
our ability to love other people to love
someone is to see them for who they are
without trying to change them you may
hope for the best for them but good luck
dragging them kicking and screaming to
your world view that's right a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still right yes
and so
it's not i never want to convince him
coerce him persuade him even if anything
i want to understand where he's coming
from yeah and that's what it comes down
to like really trying to understand and
you know
when you have an understanding you can
have brutally honest truth with one
another
because you know josh could you know say
to me um hey man i noticed whatever you
know and insert criticism there
and i understand that he's trying to
help me he's not trying to put me down
he's not trying to feel better than me
yes and uh instead of me getting
offended
um i will look at it and like and try to
understand like okay where is he coming
from
the problem is there's a lot of
friendships where people
they they do just want to put the other
person down
and that's we really we've got to watch
out for that for sure i
i think that's super important um
it comes back to that word that nobody
likes um that vulnerability like i've
got to put myself in a position where
you could hurt me if you wanted to yeah
yeah and i am going to trust that you
won't and
um i'm gonna be like you mentioned i'm
gonna be open about what i need i'm
gonna be clear about that
and
i'm going to
take a knee here and if you do the same
thing then we can do anything right if
that's the way we approach one another
we can do anything right i would i would
you know posit that no one can really
um like make you angry or hurt you so to
say yeah if you if you do open yourself
up and allow them to have that space in
your heart then that is a decision that
you make so i allow four or five people
in yeah and i actually called them and
told them
yeah like hey i've given you permission
so if you speak into i had one buddy the
story he's a 50 he's the ceo of a lawn
care company right uh but he's an old
buddy that i trust and he's about 10
years older than me and
somebody posted something about how what
a loser i was and i screenshot it and
responded back and i'm not gonna lie my
response was hilarious it was pretty
funny i thought it was great
and he calls me laughing he's like dude
i just saw that hilarious and i was like
yeah i was great and he goes take it
down
and i said no man that's super funny
because it's super funny and he goes
that's not who you want to be take it
down yeah and i got pissed then i got
indignant and i took it down yeah and
cause i know that he didn't call me
because i had a funnier joke than he did
that day right he was just some random
guy driving his mower in texas and
realized this guy thought that was funny
but it put him in this all right he had
my best interest at heart 100 percent
vice versa right if i ever call him so
um it's it's being able to hear that man
yeah you got to be you got to be careful
with who you open that up to oh yeah
josh has definitely talked me out of
responding to some trolls here and there
for sure because i used to respond and
be funny and witty and make light of it
um but yeah uh he's definitely talking
about that before too the problem is
it's always escalating in any loving
relationship we want to de-escalate yes
because what he was talking about
earlier like i don't have the power to
upset you john you have the power to
upset you
and that's one of the most difficult
things to realize because my daughter
can upset me from she's nine and she can
upset me but actually she can't
she only can if i give her that power
it's within me to determine whether or
not i react in a particular way and the
same thing is true with a online troll
as well and we have
we could talk about that forever we have
a culture that
man we have just given the keys to the
kids and
they found themselves responsible for
the emotional reactivity of the adults
in their lives and they can't carry that
what a great i mean if
if a group of if a generation of parents
would just stop and be like wait a
minute you're 10. we don't let you drive
or drink beer so you can't hurt my
feelings like go you know i need you to
do finish your dishes or whatever the
thing yeah the world would change on a
dime
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show
your stories are incredible and each
person's situation is unique and for
years people from all over the world
have been asking if i do private
counseling or private coaching sessions
for them or for their spouse and as much
as i'd love to i can't realistically do
one-on-one coaching sessions with every
single person it's just not possible but
that's exactly why i wrote my new book
own your past change your future within
the pages of this book is exactly what i
would say if you and i were sitting down
together at a table looking for the next
right move for you to make in your
relationships or to help you live a more
whole and peaceful life as you read
through each section of this book i will
show you how to look and own the roads
from your past and head to the new roads
of a well life moving forward go to
johndaloni.com to get your copy today
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right so that was it i hope you
enjoyed that and once again i was wrong
i was wrong i'm gonna figure out how to
change my ways kelly will you be my
friend
definitely
anytime somebody answers you with an ly
word they're not telling you the truth
that hurt
in my heart but that's okay that's okay
i hope you enjoyed it and i've got some
more conversations coming up with the
minimalist and others and um i'm so
grateful that you joined us as we wrap
up today's show oh look at this the beat
i'm not a beatles fan am i allowed to
say that
the joe cocker version of this song is
so much better
same team right here song is with a
little help from my friends and it goes
like this
what would you think if i sang out of
tune would you stand up and walk out on
me lend me your ears and i'll sing you a
song and i'll try not to sing out of key
ah
i get by with a little help from my
friends
um i get high with a little help from my
friends
i'm gonna try a little help from my
friends
do you need anybody i need somebody to
love
could it be anybody i want somebody to
love
we all get my little help from our
friends we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode we talked
about how i was
battling you know being overwhelmed with
my career as well as trying to balance
the three bands i'm in oh yeah yeah yeah
did you quit one of the bands i haven't
yet but i'm working on it what a sucker
dude
what a chump and i was told not to be
jealous of his relationship with this
person and not to come between him and
his family if he required celery at
every meal
and he chewed it with his mouth open so
loud
hey babe uh i love you but the salary
can we do gum and he's like celery stays
don't get between me and my vegetables
then you would know i have a choice to
make i feel like i'm not ready to marry
her i'm not sure if it's what i should
do if we're meant to be together if i'm
even fit for marriage at this point in
life or ever even then break up with her
and let her go man i'm not sure if if
i'm just self-sabotaging and i do this
in any relationship i'm in 100 yes